AS A FEINT HE DIDN'T WATCH IT AS
A ARE REUNITED FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE THE.S YOU PICKE
PUCK IN THE SCORE FIRST, THEY
BEAT THIS HEAD.
PICK RIGHT BENCH.
TRY TO CATCH HIM IN THE LINETY E
SEASON.
OUT THEY JOIN THE RUSH TO LINE.E
GLASS ITEMS PERSIST BACK TO IS
THAT IT IS
ANOTHER RIDING
AWAY.
20 SECONDS REMAIN IN THE DOUBLB.
?
THEY TRY TO FIGHT THEIR WAY
THROUGH THIS ONE AND THIS IS
PRETTY SOLID CHECK SIDE SHE
PUCK IN, S THE CROSS SO
THAT COMING THERE
LELE THE PENALTY
HE STEPS OUT WITH HIM AT THE
LINE.
HE DISHES AHEAD FOR
>> THE FACE-OFF IS IT.
TAYLOR CROSSEDTO TRAP UP ON THE
HE'S PUTTING ON A HIT THERE COLD
GETS IT BACK HE'S ALL OVER. AWA.
>> NOT AT
FIRES JUGGLED AND GOALTENDERS
HALL WITH THE SAVE TOUCH PASS